Hallo!
Hallo Janusz!
Hi!
Und hallo liebe Zuschauer von Easy German.
Wir sind wieder live bei YouTube heute.
Und zwar seht ihr Janusz Hamerski, hallo Janusz!
Wo bist du gerade?
Ich bin jetzt vor allen Dingen live, das ist
das Wichtigste.
Ich glaube, wir haben so was noch nie so richtig
gemacht in dieser Form, oder?
Doch.
Auch auf der Straße, mit Manuel?
Pscht!
Das ist ein Geheimnis, Janusz!
Ja, liebe Zuschauer, Janusz hat jetzt schon
das Geheimnis unserer heutigen Show gespoilert.
Ganz so ein großes Geheimnis ist es nicht,
denn wir haben das schon angekündigt in unserem
Titel.
Wir sind heute live auf der Straße, aber
Janusz und ich sind gar nicht auf der Straße,
wir sitzen zu Hause.
Wir schalten gleich zu Manuel.
Vorneweg ein paar Infos für euch: Wir probieren
heute mal was Neues, wir wissen nicht, wie
es funktioniert.
Wir schauen mal, wie es funktioniert.
Dieses Video wird auch kein Podcast sein.
Normalerweise machen wir mittwochs immer einen
Live-Podcast, aber dieses Video ist heute
mal ein neues Format.
Und ganz wichtig, wie ihr seht: Es gibt keine
Untertitel hier unten.
Wir sind live, wir können nicht live übersetzen.
We don't have subtitles in this format, aber
morgen wird es in diesem Video Untertitel
geben.
Ihr könnt einfach hier unten auf "CC" klicken
und dann könnt ihr deutsche Untertitel einschalten.
Und Janusz, wir beide müssen jetzt ein bisschen
langsam und deutlich sprechen.
Wir fragen mal unsere Zuschauer: Könnt ihr
uns gut hören?
Schreibt uns mal einen Kommentar und ja, dann
gibt es nicht mehr viel zu sagen, außer,
dass wir jetzt gleich mal gucken, wo Manuel
ist.
Janusz, bist du schon gespannt?
Oh, da ist er schon!
Hallo Manuel!
Hallo Cari, hallo Janusz.
- Hi!
- Ich berichte live von der Eberswalder Straße
U-Bahn-Station.
Ja, erzähl uns, was ist das für ein Stadtteil,
in dem du gerade bist?
Was ist das überhaupt für eine Stadt?
Wir sind in Berlin, ich bin auch gar nicht
so weit von euch entfernt, wenn ich das verraten
darf, und ich bin im Prenzlauer Berg, umgeben
von sehr, sehr vielen Menschen.
Hier ist viel los an dieser Kreuzung, die
schauen mich jetzt alle mit großen Augen
an, was ich hier mache.
Und ich finde das total aufregend, dass wir
das mal versuchen, live von der Straße zu
senden.
Ja, das Motto von Easy German ist ja "Learn
German From the Streets".
Meistens machen wir das vorproduziert.
Wir machen Interviews auf der Straße und
dann gibt es Untertitel.
Heute bist du live auf der Straße, Manuel.
Weißt du schon, was du heute machen wirst
auf der Straße?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Du hast gesagt: "Geh doch einfach mal zu der
U-Bahn-Station und von da aus sagen wir dir
dann, wo du hingehen sollst."
Also ich bin gespannt.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich einiges vorbereitet,
einige Ideen haben wir hier.
Ich wollte dir ein paar Challenges geben,
ne?
- Okay.
Kennst du noch dieses gute alte Format des
"Scavenger Hunts"?
Ja klar, eine "Schnitzeljagd" sagt man auf
Deutsch.
Genau, das machen wir jetzt live und wir geben
dir so kleine Aufgaben, die du erfüllen musst,
und wir gucken mal, ob das gut funktioniert.
Alles klar.
- Bist du bereit, Manuel?
Ich bin bereit geboren.
Manuel, die erste Aufgabe ist, dass du oben
in die U-Bahn-Station reingehst und die Menschen
begrüßt, die aus der nächsten U-Bahn rauskommen.
Ach du Scheiße.
Okay, Moment, da muss ich mir eine Maske aufsetzen.
Ja, das … ist das eine gute Idee?
Das ist eine fantastische Idee.
Es gehört ja auch zur Berliner Freundlichkeit,
dass man "Hallo" sagt, wenn die Leute aus
der U-Bahn kommen.
Ja, Manuel geht jetzt in die U-Bahn-Station.
Janusz, es gibt eine Frage … Oh, Janusz
ist weggegangen, na gut.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen.
Hallo, herzlich willkommen!
Herzlich willkommen an der Eberswalder, hallo.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen an der Eberswalder Straße.
Hallo, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo!
Schön, dass es euch gibt.
Ja, Mission erfüllt.
Da fährt sie, die U-Bahn.
Wow!
Das war gut, das war richtig krass.
Das war, das war schon alles, Manuel?
Ja, ich dachte, es geht weiter.
Schnitzeljagd, so viel Akku habe ich nämlich
nicht.
Ach so.
Eine kleine Information für euch: Wir haben
nicht so viel Batterie auf Manuels Handy.
Also, Manuel, dein Handy ist jetzt voll, aber
wir haben Angst, dass es gleich leer ist.
Richtig.
Okay, in der Zwischenzeit gibt es eine Frage
von André für Janusz.
Janusz, wie viele Gitarren hast du?
Ich habe 12 Gitarren, aber gerade heute vor
einer Stunde habe ich mit Izabela gesprochen
und sie hat mir verspro… sie hat mir versprochen,
mir dabei zu helfen, die meisten von meinen
Gitarren zu verkaufen.
Und ich verkaufe sie sehr billig, also falls
jemand eine wunderschöne Gitarre braucht,
meldet euch.
Oh Gott.
- Okay, das machen wir beim nächsten Video.
Manuel, du bist sehr schnell aus der U-Bahn
rausgegangen.
Deine nächste Aufgabe war eigentlich herauszufinden,
was ein U-Bahn-Ticket kostet.
Das weiß ich auswendig.
2,80 Euro kostet ein Einzelticket oder 2,70
Euro.
Okay, dann hast du das geschafft.
Ich wollte ein bisschen … - Wie bitte?
Drei Euro mittlerweile höre ich hier, Live-Korrektur.
Danke dir!
Ich fahr' immer mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja, das ist praktisch.
Manuel, die nächste Aufgabe ist: Gehe zu
unserer alten Wohnung und schaue nach, was
gerade los ist.
Das trifft sich ja, da bin ich gerade auf
dem Weg hin.
Hab' mir schon gedacht, dass es so ungefähr
in diese Richtung geht.
Was da los ist?
Also soll ich da auch klingeln?
Nee.
Nein, nur mal gucken, was da so los ist.
Okay.
Musst du durchs Fenster gucken.
Ja, du kannst uns das Fenster zeigen quasi.
Ah okay.
Also tatsächlich habt ihr damals, das dürfen
wir ja jetzt sagen, hier oben gewohnt.
Ja, nicht ganz.
- Nein.
Nee, eines weiter, ne?
- Nee, da …
Nee, zurück.
- Auf der anderen Seite, zurück.
Nein, nicht zurück.
Ja, doch, da!
- Da!
Da!
Da ist das Fenster.
Genau.
Da haben wir gewohnt.
Ja, man sieht jetzt nichts, das ist ja schade.
Da standen früher immer viele Flaschen von
dir drin.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Dann … kannst du uns mal kurz sagen, was
nebenan in der Kneipe geht.
Die Insel, das ist eine typische Berliner
Kneipe, eine Alt-Berliner Kneipe, kann man
sagen.
Dort sitzen viele Leute und trinken Bier oder
vielleicht nicht.
Es gibt nur zwei Tische, glaube ich.
Die Insel?
- Oh, da sind sie schon.
Ja, die hast du hinter dir, wir sehen die
hinter dir schon.
- Da ist sie!
Da ist sie, die Insel.
Die Insel.
Guten Abend.
Möchten Sie kurz Hallo sagen?
Wir machen gerade einen Livestream im Internet.
Hallo!
- Wie schmeckt das Bier?
Alle Gute für alle!
Alles Gute für alle!
Das ist die Berliner Freundlichkeit.
- Danke!
Danke, tschüss!
Liebe Grüße an unsere ehemaligen Nachbarn.
Schön, Manuel, wie du dort bekannt wirst.
Ja, Janusz, was ist dein bisheriges Fazit
von unserem Livestream?
Ja, ich bin total aufgeregt, das ist wunderschön.
Ich hab' das Gefühl, es ist richtig live.
Alles kann passieren.
Manuel kann angefahren werden von irgendeinem
Fahrrad oder angepöbelt werden von irgendeinem
freundlichen Berliner, und das gefällt mir.
- Könnte alles passieren.
Ich hab' das Gefühl … - Ja, das … das
gefällt mir, genau.
Ja.
Ich hab' das Gefühl, es ist live, es, ich
bin dabei, ja.
- Ja.
Oh, jemand hat dich erkannt.
Ich habe gehört, jemand schreit "Easy German".
- Hallo!
Wir sind gerade live auf YouTube.
Möchtest du Hallo sagen?
- Ja, gerne.
Okay, dann komm mal rum.
Wie heißt du denn?
Ich bin Jana.
Hallo Jana!
- Hi Jana!
Aus welchem Land kommst du?
Ich komme aus den Niederlanden.
Aus den Niederlanden?
Und ich habe, ich habe ein Jahr lang geübt
für mein C2-Diplom
Ja?
Und ich habe es geschafft.
Wuhu, High Five!
- Yay!
Und ich hab' sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht,
eure Videos anzuschauen.
Danke schön!
- Fantastisch!
Fantastisch.
- Das ist so cool!
Fantastisch!
Es war mein Ziel, also, ich bin in Berlin,
ich muss Easy German Leute treffen.
Ja, schau mal, Cari und Janusz sind auch da.
Wirklich?
Hi!
Die winken dir jetzt.
Hallo!
- Hi.
- Das ist super cool!
Alles Gute Jana.
Danke!
Ciao!
Ja, schön!
Perfekt.
Wir haben eine Frage an dich, Manuel, von
Trusty Turky.
Er schreibt: "Kannst du in, nach Moabit kommen?"
Klar, allerdings dann später, weil das schaffe
ich jetzt nicht, bis der Akku alle ist.
Okay, dann haben wir eine neue Challenge von
Costas.
Er sagt: "Manuel, trink mal ein Bier für
mich."
Das stand auch auf meiner Liste, vielleicht
können wir das jetzt spontan machen.
- Okay.
Okay, ja, dann muss ich erst mal einen Ort
suchen, wo ich ein Bier käuflich erwerben
kann.
Ja, das ist… - Manuel.
Hier bei dem Gemüseladen, die haben Bier.
Okay.
Es gibt da ein Geschäft und ich würde dich
gleichzeitig auch fragen: Kannst du mal herausfinden,
was aktuell die Bananen kosten?
Und dann musst du reingehen und ein Bier kaufen.
Alles klar, darf das alkoholfrei sein?
Das darf es.
So, ich muss erst mal wahrscheinlich um Erlaubnis
fragen, ob ich hier mit der Kamera rein darf.
Also die Bananen liegen hier.
Und was die kosten werde ich jetzt herausfinden.
- Ja.
Anonym fragt: "Manuel, hast du keine Powerbank?"
Doch, aber das externe Mikrofon belegt den
einzigen Steckplatz, deswegen kann ich nicht
beides reinmachen.
Hallo, darf ich mit der Kamera reinkommen?
Ja?
Und das live filmen?
Okay, ich habe auch eine Frage, zwei Fragen.
Ganz schön schwierig hier, mit einer Hand.
Ja, ja, Manuel.
Oh, da läuft Techno-Musik, wie in vielen
Berliner Geschäften.
Also erst mal suche ich mir … - Nee, das
ist, bei denen läuft immer Hip-Hop.
So, die Bier-Auswahl ist groß.
Ja.
Dort habe ich immer mein Bier geholt.
Stimmt.
Als ihr noch hier lebtet, ja?
Ja.
- Ja.
Akuab fragt auch: "Janusz, was hast du, wo
ist das Bier?"
Mit dem Bier fangen wir etwas später an,
weil wir haben noch ein zusätzliches Treffen
um 20 Uhr, glaube ich, und dann trinken wir
ein oder zwei Bierchen, ja.
Verstehe.
Also ich habe mir schon einen Drink gemacht,
Manuel.
- Wie bitte?
Ich kann gleich …
Für Easy German.
Ich mach' mich mal kurz mute.
Ja.
Manuel ist jetzt kurz raus, das gibt uns ein
bisschen Zeit, hier Fragen zu beantworten.
Etmir möchte gern wissen: "Wie viel kostet
ein Bier?"
Und das können wir vielleicht gleich Manuel
fragen.
Und the Immortal Chess schreibt: "Hallo Cari,
ich habe heute Geburtstag.
Wäre schön, wenn Sie mich grüßen."
Das mache ich hiermit.
Janusz und ich gratulieren dir.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Und dann haben wir eine Frage von TheFamousRat
und TheFamousRat schreibt: "Denkt ihr, dass
ihr jetzt langsamer als normal sprecht oder
sprecht ihr immer in dieser Geschwindigkeit?"
Janusz, was sagst du?
Also ich spreche … - Bier habe ich dir doch
schon gegeben, oder?
Ich spreche normal und Cari spricht wesentlich
langsamer.
Ja?
- Und ich spreche immer … - Ich spreche
…
Ja, ich spreche immer langsam, weil ich denke
auch langsam.
Ich bin älter und ich bin, ich komme ja nicht
aus Deutschland, sondern aus Polen, und ich
muss mir immer zweimal überlegen, was ich
eigentlich sagen will, und deshalb ja.
So, ich sehe, Manuel ist schon wieder draußen
aus dem Geschäft.
Es gibt eine Frage an dich, Manuel, zwei Fragen,
und zwar einmal …
Ja, warte mal.
Erst mal möchte ich sagen: Mission accomplished.
Prost!
Ja, bravo!
Und das Kilo Bananen kostet 1,99 Euro, eine
Banane geschätzt 30 Cent.
Wow, das ist ja nicht viel.
- Sehr gut!
Du hast bisher alles geschafft, Manuel.
Wir haben jetzt zwei Fragen an dich, und zwar
gibt es eine Frage: "Wie viel kostet das Bier
in einem Geschäft?"
1,50 Euro, in einem Späti, in einem Spätkauf.
Also, im Supermarkt ist es günstiger.
Das ist gut zu wissen in Berlin.
Es gibt dort diese kleinen Geschäfte, die
auf der Straße sind, und das nennt man in
Berlin ein "Späti".
Und da ist es tatsächlich teurer, aber wenn
ihr in einen Aldi geht oder Lidl oder Rewe
oder Edeka oder Netto, wir haben viele Supermärkte,
da ist es billiger.
Manuel, Frage zwei an dich ist: "Bist du schon
geimpft?"
Yes!
Vollständig geimpft.
Ja.
Toll!
Schön!
Dann gibt es zwei Fragen an Manuel, die kann
ich direkt selber beantworten.
Und zwar gibt es Leute, Logit möchte, dass
du zu Risa Chicken gehst und Elan möchte,
dass du eine Currywurst isst.
Da würde ich sagen, das ist nichts für dich,
oder?
Richtig, ist nicht so mein präferiertes Essen.
Außerdem …
Ja, du bist nämlich Vegetarier.
Ja, Veganer.
Und außerdem habe ich keine Hände mehr frei,
also es ist … alles, was jetzt noch kompliziert
wird, ist schwierig.
Okay, und noch … - Jetzt könntest du vielleicht
noch …
Ja, Janusz?
Jetzt könnte er höchstens noch eine Zigarette
zwischen die Lippen schieben, aber sonst nicht.
Ja, dann gibt es eine Frage an Janusz, von
Rick.
Er fragt: "Was heißt Ordah?"
Ordah!
Dein T-Shirt.
- Es gab eine Stelle in einem polnischen,
einem englischen Parlament, wo der Parlaments-Marshall
oder wie er auch immer heißt, die Menschen,
die waren sehr aufgeregt.
Es war diese Brexit-Zeit in England und er
hat sie zur Order gerufen.
Und er hat ständig gerufen: "Order!
Order!"
Und weil er einen englischen, wahrscheinlich,
London-mäßigen Akzent hatte, so diese typische
englische Aussprache, hieß das: Ordah!
Ordah!
Sehr gut, Janusz.
Danke schön für die ausführliche Erklärung.
Manuel, wo bist du jetzt?
Zeig uns bitte die Umgebung.
Ich stehe jetzt mittlerweile auf der Kastanienallee,
die relativ bekannt ist aus vielen Easy German
Videos.
Und ich stehe vor einem sehr bekannten Biergarten,
der "Prater Garten" heißt.
Hier ist der Eingang.
Prater Garten.
Und genau, da treffen sich die Menschen und
trinken Bier zusammen.
Den Biergarten sieht man jetzt nicht.
- Können alle da rein?
Können alle da rein?
Kannst du da reingehen und uns den Biergarten
zeigen?
Das könnte schwierig werden, weil ich ja
schon ein Bier in der Hand hab'.
Ah, okay.
- Ich weiß nicht, ich kann ja mal so ein
paar Schritte machen.
Also hier sind auf jeden Fall die Fahrräder,
denn viele Menschen kommen mit dem Fahrrad,
und dahinter beginnt dann der Biergarten und
der Biergarten ist heute offen.
Offen.
- Eigen…
Eigentlich müsste es heißen "geöffnet",
aber umgangssprachlich darf man auch "offen"
sagen.
Danke für diese Live-Korrektur von der Straße.
Manuel korrigiert Deutsch auf Schildern.
Ja, genau.
Manuel, wir haben eine Aufgabe für dich,
und zwar möchten wir gerne, dass du jetzt
die Feuerwache suchst.
In Deutschland gibt es eine Feuerwehr.
Was macht die Feuerwehr, was ist das?
Die Feuerwehr löscht Brände unter anderem,
sie machen ja noch viel mehr.
Sie pumpen auch Wasser aus Kellern, wenn Keller
zu laufen.
Sie retten Katzen und Menschen von Hunden
… von Bäumen und aus Gebäuden.
Sie kümmern sich um Gaslecks.
Sie machen viele wichtige Dinge in einem städtischen
Leben.
Ja.
Also vielleicht habt ihr es schon verstanden.
Feuerwehr ist auf Englisch "Fire Brigade".
Manuel sucht jetzt die Feuerwehr.
Und auf diesem Weg, Manuel, hast du noch eine
Aufgabe.
Wir möchten, dass du einen interessanten
deutschen Sticker findest oder ein Poster
mit etwas Interessantem drauf, was du uns
zeigst.
Es gibt zum Beispiel gerade die Wahl.
Vielleicht gibt es ein interessantes Wahlplakat,
in sechs Wochen wird gewählt.
Und Janusz, während Manuel sucht, beantworten
wir noch ein paar Fragen.
Wie wäre das?
Okay.
Und zwar ist eine Frage von Alberto: "Will
this Live be uploaded as a video after it
ends?"
Ja, dieses Video wird hier auf YouTube bleiben.
Das ist eine sehr einfache Frage.
La Escalera fragt: "Janusz, wer ist dein Lieblingsgitarrist?"
Oh, das ist so schwierig, aber Stevie Ray
Vaughan mit Sicherheit.
Also die Intensität, mit der er spielt, ist
einfach unglaublich.
Ich habe gerade gestern oder heute ein Reaction-Video
gesehen.
Also ein zwanzigjähriger Amerikaner, der
bis jetzt nie was von ihm gesehen hat, hat
das zum ersten Mal gesehen und der Junge ist
da richtig … voll vom Hocker gefallen, ja?
Okay, das reicht schon als Antwort.
Danke, Manuel, äh, Janusz.
Ich habe ein Poster gefunden, das ich für
sehr relevant und aktuell wichtig halte, und
auch schön, schön designt.
Und das sieht so aus.
Gleich in doppelter Ausführung.
"Klimakrise stoppen.
Unsere Zukunft ist wichtiger als Profit."
Es ist ja gerade dieser Klimabericht herausgekommen
und ich denke …
Und da war auch ein Demo-Aufruf.
Da war ein Datum, ne?
Richtig, das habe ich mir jetzt leider nicht
gemerkt.
Ja?
16.8. in Berlin, Demonstration.
Vielleicht treffen wir uns da mit unseren
Zuschauern.
Vielleicht gehen wir dahin.
Diogo fragt: "An Manuel und an Cari, kann
Manuel Polnisch?
Und Cari, kannst du Polnisch?"
Ich würde sagen …
Ja.
Du, du musst das selber beantworten, Manuel.
Sehr wenig.
Trocheczke, ein bissle, ein bisschen.
Dzień dobry!
Nie mówię po polsku.
Bardzo dobrze mówię po polsku.
- A ty, Manuel?
Manuel, mówisz po polsku?
Tak!
- Bardzo dobrze…
Okay.
Bardzo trochę!
- Dziękuję.
Alles vergessen.
Es ist lange her, dass ich dort gelebt habe
leider.
Ja.
Schade.
Manuel, hier ist noch eine Frage.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie der Name ausgesprochen
wird, vielleicht Катя, Катя oder so?
"Welches Wort ist eurer Meinung nach das Wort
der Jugendlichen 2021?"
Das Jugendwort 2021.
Manuel, bist du up-to-date in der Jugendsprache
Überhaupt nicht, ich habe keine Ahnung, was
die jungen Leute sagen.
Okay, dann … Ich kann auch nicht helfen,
ich bin alt.
Janusz, du bist ja der Jüngste von uns.
Wie sieht's bei dir aus?
Im Herzen.
Irgendwas mit Babo und Chabo, wie war das
noch mal?
Das waren die Jugendwörter von 2016, glaube
ich.
Uff, okay, dann bin ich tatsächlich schon
alt.
Manuel, eine Frage für dich.
Siddharth fragt: "Gibt es viele vegetarische
Restaurants in Deutschland?"
Es gibt sehr viele in Berlin.
Das ist definitiv ein Vorteil, wenn man in
Berlin wohnt.
Man hat sehr viel Auswahl.
In Deutschland mehr als in vielen anderen
Ländern, aber je ländlicher es wird, desto
schwieriger wird es.
Also in den ländlichen Gebieten in Deutschland
sind Fleischgerichte doch sehr populär, nach
wie vor.
Und … - Viel populärer, ja.
Hier habe ich ein Update, aber Moment, ich
mache mich mal kurz auf Mute und frage mal
kurz was.
Ja, okay.
Da gibt es noch eine Zwischenfrage gleich.
Wir haben so viele schöne Fragen.
Schreibt uns gerne Fragen hier in die Kommentare.
Wir freuen uns, eure Fragen zu beantworten.
So, also ich habe versucht, die Feuerwehrmänner
zu interviewen, das hat leider nicht funktioniert,
aber ich habe die Feuerwache gefunden.
Die ist wirklich wunderschön, muss man sagen,
die ist nämlich ganz knallrot angestrichen.
Und davor ist Parkverbot, damit die Feuerwehr
immer gut rauskommt.
Ja, wo bist du jetzt?
Wie heißt diese Straße, Manuel?
Oh, das ist jetzt peinlich, das weiß ich
nicht.
Oderberger.
Oderberger ist das!
- Aber es wird eingeblendet.
Das ist die Oderberger Straße und ich bin
schon ganz gespannt.
Es geht gleich weiter mit der nächsten Challenge,
vorher beantworten wir noch drei Fragen, okay?
Okay.
Und zwar fragt Marshall: "Manuel, was ist
dein Lieblings-vegetarisches Gericht?"
Oh, Manuel, du bist eingefroren.
Oh!
Oh, jetzt sehe ich dich wieder, ja.
- Bei mir nicht.
Hallo?
- Das Internet scheint da schlecht zu sein
vor der Feuerwehr.
Ja, aber vielleicht … - Ja.
Ich habe ein Lieblings… - Siehst du Manuel?
Hört ihr mich?
Ja.
- Ich habe … - Echt alles schlecht.
Aber ich höre, ich sehe alles perfekt, Cari.
Okay, also mein Lieblingsrestaurant ist ein
…
Okay, dann ist mein Internet schlecht.
Ja.
Du bist ein bisschen hinterher, Cari, ein
paar Sekunden.
Vielleicht musst du kurz raus und wieder rein.
Um die Frage zu beantworten: Es gibt sehr
gute vegane Restaurants in Berlin.
- Ja, mache ich, bis gleich!
Bis gleich!
Zum Beispiel einen veganen Vietnamesen in
Pankow, den ich sehr mag, und auch einen Burger,
der heißt "Vincent Vegan".
Das ist so Fast Food, beides sehr lecker.
Und Manuel, du bist jetzt schon in der Nähe?
Oder nein, du entfernst dich, weil dort, ein
paar Meter weiter gibt es diese Gedenkstelle,
wo die Mauer gestanden hat.
Weißt du?
Da an der Ecke.
Gehst du da einmal …
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu weit
zu Fuß, denn wir haben ja nicht mehr so viel
Zeit.
Mal schauen, was Cari gleich noch für eine
Challenge hat, in welche Richtung es dann
geht.
- Okay.
Cari, hörst du uns?
Hallo, hallo?
- Okay.
Okay, wir hören dich.
- Ja, aber mein Internet ist immer noch sehr
schlecht.
Hört ihr mich?
Ja, wir hören dich, aber das Bild von dir
… - Mandy fragt: "Why did Cari disappear?",
weil das Internet in Deutschland schlecht
ist.
Ja, das ist leider ein großes Problem.
- Verdammt.
Wir hätten wahrscheinlich uns mit dem Kabel
verbinden sollen.
Aber was ist denn die letzte Challenge, Cari?
Dann kann ich mich schon mal auf den Weg machen.
Cari ist schon wieder weg, dann muss ich diese
letzte Challenge dir geben.
Takeover, Takeover, hier bin ich!
Willst du dich hier hinsetzen?
Ja!
Okay, bitte sehr.
Ich muss was hören.
Ja.
Okay, das ist 'ne gute Idee.
– Manuel!
Das nenne ich Improvisation.
Mein Internet ist kaputt.
Woran liegt das?
Es liegt am Internet in Deutschland.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das Internet in Deutschland ist schlecht.
Manuel, bist du bereit für deine letzte Challenge?
Nee, es gibt noch drei.
- Ja.
Oh Gott!
Challenge Nummer eins ist von … habe ich
vergessen, von Rafał.
Er möchte gerne, dass du ein Graffiti findest,
das sollte nicht so schwierig sein in Berlin.
Und meine nächste Challenge ist: Geh in den
Mauerpark, der bekannte Mauerpark, und vielleicht
findest du auf dem Weg ein Graffiti.
Okay, los geht's!
- Ja, und auf dem Weg gibt es diese Stelle
mit den Bildern von der Wa… von der Mauer.
Janusz gibt dir noch eine Challenge, während
ich versuche, mein Internet neu zu verbinden.
Also, Janusz spricht von der Bernauer Straße,
eine bekannte Stelle.
- Ja, aber das ist viel kürzer.
Diese Ecke, die ich meine, die müsstest du
jetzt schon sehen.
Die kommt auf deiner linken Seite.
Da an der Ecke, da gibt es ganz viele Fotos
und so aufgestellte … musst du gleich sehen,
ja?
Also quasi …
Das ist wirklich wie eine Schnitzeljagd, was
wir hier machen.
- Ja.
Und zwar ist, ist das noch viel früher als
die (der) Mauerpark.
Das kommt gleich, gleich musst du das auf
der linken Seite sehen.
Okay, ich halte in der Zwischenzeit nach Graffitis
Ausschau.
Also es gibt natürlich viele so Schmierereien
in Berlin, das würde ich jetzt aber nicht
unbedingt als Graffiti bezeichnen.
Vielleicht finden wir noch was Schöneres
auf dem Weg, mal schauen.
- Okay.
Okay.
Und die Stelle, von der du sprichst.
Ach, ich weiß, welche du meinst.
Du meinst diese Häuserwand, wo die …
Ja, genau.
- Ich glaube, da sind so Fluchtversuche abgebildet.
Nee, das ist später in der Bernauer Straße,
aber hier, guck dich … auf der linken Seite
kommst du an eine Ecke und dort gibt es auch
diese, so Ausstellungskasten mit Bildern und
auf der … ja.
Ich weiß, welche Stelle du meinst.
Da ist Cari, juhu!
Also …
Cari ist zurück, ja.
Es gab schon … - Toll gemeistert.
Ich habe jetzt ein Kabel angeschlossen, Manuel.
Sehr gut.
Ist doch erstaunlich, dass mein Internet hier
von unterwegs so erstaunlich stabil ist.
Ja.
So.
- Guck mal, Mohammed hat das schon gesagt:
"Nimmst du Ethernet-Kabel statt Wi-Fi?"
Genau das habe ich gemacht, Mohammed.
Live Tech-Support.
So, ich bin jetzt hier an der Stelle, die
Janusz sich gewünscht hat, und zwar ist das
die Schwedter Straße.
Und hier ist abgebildet, wie es hier aussah,
als die Mauer gefallen ist 1989, als die Menschenmassen
durch die Mauer geströmt sind in beide Richtungen,
vom Osten Berlin in den Westen und umgekehrt.
Das waren emotionale Momente und die sind
hier verewigt.
Und jetzt gehe ich in Richtung Mauerpark.
Den sieht man jetzt hier schon hinter mir
und ist ein relativ großer Park, aber ich
werde ihn jetzt gleich betreten.
Ja, kannst du bitte noch für Rafał ein Graffiti
finden?
Ja, ich bin auf der Suche nach einem schönen
Graffiti.
Es gibt viele so Schmierereien, aber wirklich
schöne Graffitis sehe ich nicht so viele.
Ich schaue.
Ja, die sieh… die findest du eher im Mauerpark.
Ja, da gibts ja nicht so viele Wände, ne?
Ja, das stimmt.
Doch, im Mauerpark gibt es noch die Reste
von der Mauer und da drauf gibt es die Graffitis.
Okay, man merkt, Janusz ist viel unterwegs
in dieser Gegend, kennt sich aus.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle kurz beklagen,
wie wenig Platz hier für die vielen Fahrräder
ist, für die vielen Fahrradfahrer.
Ganz kleine Radwege und dafür viel Platz
für die Autos.
Das ist wirklich schade in Berlin, dass die
Infrastruktur noch nicht für Fahrräder optimiert
ist.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein … - Na ja.
Das ist …
Unser beliebtes … - Das ist ein …
Podcast-Segment "das nervt", live hier bei
YouTube.
Wenn ihr das noch öfter hören möchtet,
wie Manuel sich aufregt oder wie ich etwas
mich aufrege, dann könnt ihr mal unseren
Podcast hören auf easygerman.fm.
Aber … - Vielleicht kennen den ja einige
noch nicht.
- Ich habe einen …
Ich habe einen neuen Namen für euch, nämlich
"klagen auf hohem Niveau".
Das ist ein gutes Wort, ja.
Manuel, wo bist du jetzt gerade?
Erzähl uns mal, wo du bist.
Ich bin jetzt hier am Eingang zum Mauerpark.
Das Wetter ist sehr schön, deswegen sind
viele Menschen hier auf der Wiese.
Und hier ist ein Straßenmusiker, den möchten
wir natürlich unterstützen, zeigen seinen
Instagram-Kanal und geben ihm ein bisschen
Geld, denn Straßenmusik ist wirklich immer
sehr schön.
Zeig mal den Instagram-Kanal.
Wie toll!
Plagu_Musix.
Und hier habe ich auch ein Graffiti, das ist
allerdings nicht schön, deswegen werde ich
es nicht zeigen.
Ja, du müsstest dann von dir rechts nach
oben gehen, da hast du die Graffitis.
Warte, die kommen gleich noch.
Manuel, geh mal bitte weiter geradeaus, einfach
geradeaus.
Du weißt schon, wohin.
Ich weiß schon, wohin?
Vielleicht.
Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Wir haben eine Frage von Chengis bekommen.
Chengis fragt: "Ist das eine Pilot-Episode?
Habt ihr den Plan, öfters live auf die Straße
zu gehen?"
Absolut.
Ihr könnt ja mal schreiben, ob das interessant
ist oder eher nicht.
Schreibt uns mal.
Und ich habe auch eine Frage.
Ja?
- Ja?
Können wir nächstes Mal quasi auch Chris
mitschicken, dass er dich quasi filmt und
dass du nicht beschäftigt bist mit dem, mit
dem Handy?
Dann kannst du noch die Bratwurst in der anderen
Hand trag… mittragen.
Das wäre vor allen Dingen meinen Armen zuliebe
eine gute Idee, denn die sind sehr …
Guck mal.
- "Ist jemand nackt auf der Wiese?", fragt
Jim.
Nicht in Berlin, so was haben wir nicht.
Bis jetzt habe ich noch keinen gesehen, aber
ich habe die Graffitis gefunden, von denen
Janusz sprach.
Und tatsächlich ist das hier auf einer Mauer,
das ist allerdings nicht die Original-Mauer,
oder?
Also zumindest nicht die Hauptmauer von damals.
Nein, aber … - Ich glaube schon.
Okay, das war tatsächlich eine zweite Challenge,
Manuel, dass du die Mauer zeigst und die aktuellen
Graffitis.
Das ist nicht die Berliner Mauer, aber es
ist tatsächlich gut zu wissen.
Der Mauerpark steht dort, wo früher die Mauer
war, also dieser Ort war früher eigentlich
eine Grenze und ein Streifen, wo man nicht
hergehen konnte.
Und heute gibt es einen Park, in dem sich
Menschen treffen, und oben im Park gibt es
eine, einen Hügel neben dem Stadion und dort
gibt es eine Mauer, wo jeder Graffiti sprühen
kann.
Und da bist du jetzt gerade, Manuel.
Genau, und hier wird auch fleißig gesprüht.
- Das sieht gut aus.
Und ich muss sagen, von hier oben ist auch
die Aussicht ganz cool.
Ich bin relativ selten hier oben, aber …
Siehst du mal.
Es ist schön!
Wir waren schon mal Silvester da, liebe Grüße
an Emanuel von yourdailygerman.com.
Er hat uns dorthin gebracht und uns diesen
Ausblick gezeigt.
Es war wirklich schön, da wird einiges gesehen.
Ich habe noch eine Challenge an Manuel.
Er soll nach unten gehen und mit den Jungs
Basketball spielen.
Das könnte schwierig werden mit dem Equipment,
das ich gleichzeitig noch in der Hand habe.
Das machen wir beim nächsten Mal, wenn wir
einen Kameramann dabei haben.
Okay, hier ist eine Frage von Nico.
Nico sagt: "Nächstes Mal soll Janusz laufen."
Genau!
- Oh, so gerne!
- Das ist mal eine gute Idee.
Da sage ich euch schon mal, da werdet ihr
nicht ganz so viel sehen.
Wieso?
- Manuel.
Natürlich!
Bin ganz schön gelaufen hier heute in 30
Minuten.
- Meint er lau…
Meint er "laufen" wirklich mit laufen oder
meint er "laufen gehen"?
Das ist jetzt die Frage.
Guck mal, das ist interessant.
Karen schreibt: "Das ist interessant, ich
habe früher in Berlin gewohnt, damals gab
es die Mauer."
Das ist ja schon lange her, aber vor über
30 Jahren stand dort, wo du jetzt bist, die
Mauer.
Ich habe gerade herausgefunden, wie man Kommentare
live einblendet.
Ist das cool?
Ja, das ist voll cool.
- Das ist fantastisch.
Andrew schreibt: "Es ist interessant und lustig.
Bitte macht das in jedem Bezirk."
Ja, und … - Alright.
Und ich habe auch eine Bitte: Lasst uns heute
die Episode so lange machen, bis dein Akku
alle ist, ja?
Das ist einfach toll.
Ja, ich glaube, das … es dauert leider nicht
mehr lange, der ist schon auf 25 Prozent.
- Oh nein.
Okay, Micky schreibt: "Geht mal zum Plötzensee,
da findet ihr nackte Menschen."
Ja, weiß nicht, ob wir die hier auf YouTube
zeigen können, aber wir können es versuchen.
Manuel, bist du bereit für deine letzte Challenge?
Natürlich.
Und zwar, die letzte Challenge an dich ist:
Geh mal zu dem Ort, wo es immer Karaoke gibt
… - Ja?
Und singe einmal was.
Genau, und dann möchten wir gerne, dass du
Karaoke singst, hier live auf YouTube.
Bravo!
Bin voll dabei.
- Also das nächste … das nächste Mal …
Das nächste Mal schicken wir Cari und ich
überlege mir die Challenges.
Wir gucken erst mal, was da los ist, ob es
da überhaupt Karaoke gibt oder eine Karaoke-Maschine.
Ach, ich bin ja schon vorbei, okay.
Also, hier kommt nun das … Erst mal möchte
ich darauf hinweisen, wie schön hier der
Fernsehturm ist im Hintergrund.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das gut sieht?
Schlecht.
Ein bisschen.
- Nee, sehr schlecht.
Eine schöne Sicht hier, aber das kann die
kleine Kamera jetzt nicht so einfangen.
Und hier, links von mir ist jetzt das Amphitheater
vom Mauerpark und hier finden regelmäßig
Karaoke-Events statt.
Genau, und da sitzen jetzt einige Leute und
für die solltest du gerne singen, Manuel.
Oh bitte, ja.
Ich brauche aber eine Karaoke-Maschine oder
einen Text.
Nein, du singst a capella, etwas von den Ärzten.
- Janusz.
Janusz, du musst die Gitarre spielen!
Okay, ich werde "Jein" vortragen.
Ja.
Oh ja, oh, was?
Wo ist Manuel?
Oh nein!
Manuel ist verschwunden.
Shit!
- Nein!
Nein!
- Ist die Batterie leer, jetzt, kurz vor dem
Singen?
- Oh nein.
Das ist aber jetzt richtig ka… - Das …
Nee, da ist er wieder.
Das wäre dramatisch.
Juhu!
- So.
- Manuel ist zurück!
Das war noch nicht der Akku, da ist nur das
Handy abgestürzt.
Okay, ich werde dann jetzt die erste Strophe
von "jein" präsentieren zum Abschluss.
Okay.
- Okay.
Aber die Leute müssen dir …
Es ist Neunzehn-sechsundneunzig
Meine Freundin ist weg und bräunt sich
In der Südsee.
– Allein?
Ja, mein Budget war klein
Na fein!
Herein, willkommen im Verein!
Ich wette, heute machen wir erneut 'ne fette
Beute
Treffen seute Bräute und lauter nette Leute
Warum dauernd trauern?
Wow, schaut euch diese Frau an!
Schande, dazu bist du imstande?!
Kaum ist deine Herzallerliebste aus dem Lande
Und du Hengst denkst längst an 'ne Andere
Was soll ich denn heulen?
Ihr wisst, dass ich meiner Freundin treu bin
Ich bin brav, aber ich traf eben my first
love
Ich darf zwar nur im Schlaf
Doch auf sie war ich schon immer scharf
Habt ihr den Blick geahnt
Den sie mir eben durchs Zimmer warf!
Oh mein Gott, wat hat der Trottel Sott
What a Pretty Woman, das Glück is' mit die
Dummen
Weiter kann ich nicht.
Wow, bravo!
Bravo, das war toll!
Und jetzt was von den Ärzten.
Was sagt das Publikum?
Es gibt vereinzelte Klatscher im Hintergrund,
aber nicht so viele.
Oh doch, da war noch einer.
Alright!
- Toll, Manuel!
Du hast alles geschafft und sogar dein Akku
hat gehalten.
Wie fühlst du dich jetzt?
Ich fühle mich gut, es war ein sehr schöner
Spaziergang mit euch und ich bin sehr gespannt
auf das Feedback und auf die Kommentare, aber
ihr wisst, uns ist nichts zu blöd, um euch
Deutschland und Berlin und die deutsche Sprache
näherzubringen.
Und es hat Spaß gemacht.
Ich freue mich auch sehr.
Ich danke euch allen, ich danke noch mal backstage
an … liebe Grüße an Chris, der hat heute
die Regie gemacht.
Liebe Grüße an Isi, die hat die Kommentare
moderiert, jemand hat gerade nach Isi gefragt.
Isi ist auch hier, aber behind-the-scenes.
Und wir werden jetzt gleich noch privat etwas
weiterfeiern, Manuel.
So sieht's aus.
Willst du uns besuchen kommen und wir trinken
ein Bier?
Oh bitte!
- Das mache ich gerne.
Bis gleich!
- Ja, prima.
Ja, bis gleich, und ich würde sagen, vielen
Dank an euch alle fürs Zusehen.
Schreibt uns gerne einen Kommentar, wir möchten
wissen: Hat euch dieses Format gefallen?
Wenn ja, machen wir das demnächst öfters.
Also Janusz oder Manuel oder ich gehen auf
die Straße.
Wir können etwas zeigen von Berlin, wir können
ein paar Live-Challenges machen, und schreibt
uns gerne einen Kommentar.
Und wenn ihr Lust habt, mehr herauszufinden
über Easy German, guckt mal auf easygerman.org.
Wir haben auch einen Podcast, zweimal die
Woche quatschen Manuel und Janusz und ich.
Und wir haben auch ein Mitgliedschafts-Programm,
mit dem ihr uns unterstützen könnt.
Und da könnt ihr auch zu unseren Videos interaktive
Übungen, Transkripte und vieles mehr bekommen.
Das geht hier unten, ihr seht den Link hier
unten eingeblendet.
Danke schön fürs Zuschauen!
Danke Manuel!
Danke schön!
- Bis bald!
- Nächstes Mal will ich laufen, bitte.
Juhu!
Machen wir.
Bis bald, ciao!
- Ciao!
Ciao!